Joe Biden has had an unfortunate gaffe
that some are saying is representative
of his underlying racism others are
saying it's representative of just his
underlying ignorant and even others are
saying it's representative of his
underlying sort of slowness and
confusion that some believe he's
experiencing cognitively Biden said poor
kids are just as smart as white kids
check it out we have this notion that
somehow if you're poor you cannot do it
poor kids are just as bright and just as
talyn's white kids wealthy kids black
kids so the interpretation is that he
meant to say poor kids are just as smart
as wealthy kids but instead he said
white kids both start with a w and then
he sort of smoothed it out by listing a
few types of kids and made it seem like
it was his plan all along
poor kids that's just are just as smart
as white kids wealthy kids Asian kids
Latino kids etc and there are two sides
here and I think ultimately that's
actually an irrelevant debate was this a
this a gaffe it was a gaffe in that it
sounded really bad is there anything
here that confirms some kind of inherent
racism by Joe Biden not inherently but
again it does not sound good there are
lots of people in this country who do
straight-up believe that white kids are
smarter than poor kids and poor kids
they mostly see as being non-white like
that's not a completely uncommon belief
in this country we know that that exists
the overwhelming majority of those
voters aren't voting in the Democratic
primary anyway so that actually seems
like a bit of a departure from the key
issue here is this evidence that Joe
Biden is inherently racist it's not
evidence by itself it is evidence that
Biden is some combination of sort of
tired and maybe out of touch in terms of
how we discuss some of these issues
today but then there's really a more
serious issue here that even if poor
kids and wealthy kids in the United
States have the same potential at birth
in some kind of you know genetic basis
there are countless studies that show
that poverty does negatively affect
academic outcomes and ultimately life
outcomes the real important issue here
is that poverty hurts the potential of
kids after they are born hunger hurts
the potential of kids to do well in
school absent parents hurt the potential
of kids lack of access to educational
resources hurt a child's potential
that's a real take away that's a real
issue and the same people on the right
who were just saying oh look at racist
Biden okay Biden may have antiquated
beliefs on race he may be racist he may
have just misspoken could be some
combination of these things but all of
those people who are just saying look at
racist Biden they don't want to deal
with the destructive effect of poverty
on educational and career outcomes
poverty really hurts your ability to do
well in school and ultimately in life if
you want to take this seriously rather
than focusing on you know the Biden
gaffe element which is not new Biden is
hugely gaffe prone and that's not
anything we've avoided talking about on
this program let's focus on dealing with
poverty which our elected officials and
primarily those on the Republican side
are completely unwilling to do
Republicans and Democrats the same on
many issues perpetuating the status quo
that continues to have the same types of
people put in elected office we've
talked about all of the ways that
Republicans and Democrats are too
similar but we've also talked about many
of the ways that Republicans and
Democrats are very different
Republicans and Democrats very different
in who as presidents they appoint to the
Supreme Court and the lower courts very
very different Republicans and Democrats
very different on net neutrality we
talked about that last week in the
context of Elizabeth Warren's new net
neutrality and most maybe as importantly
public Internet proposal and Democrats
and Republicans very different in terms
of what should the country be willing to
do and by the country I mean people with
our tax money in terms of how that tax
money is allocated to deal with poverty
to deal with hunger and in order to
really do that we have to understand the
destructive effect that poverty has
kids in their ability to do well in life
and you can pick celebrities or athletes
who were dealt a bad hand and did really
well they are statistically irrelevant I
don't mean I don't care about them but I
mean statistically that is not even
really an important part of the mobility
conversation that we need to be having
and that's really the issue that we
should be talking about here but a gaffe
no question about it evidence that Biden
is inherently racist certainly not by
itself but very very much hitting on an
important issue that even though poor
kids and wealthy kids may have the same
potential at least in some hypothetical
sense the reality of poverty is
absolutely crushing